pour merci d'avoir que c'était de venir
à cette fête cette belle fête organisée
par berthe mirena et son pass daniel
retat bref toute une équipe qui s'est
appliqué pour cette fête des voisins au
travail je remercie aussi dans nos
invités qui ont visité notre site ce
matin
en l'occurrence la clinique saint paul
et la direction de l'aviation civile
merci à tous fiers d'être parmi nous
nous allons déménager au mois de
novembre décembre
donc nous avons souhaité rencontre un
petit peu des voisins que nous avons
côtoyé pendant sept ans nombre d'années
afin de les lire également un petit tour
voire avant de partir voisins voisines
les relations sont bonnes il ressent
toujours bons à 3 et ouazine on essaie
de faire de notre mieux
donc je pense que ça ira donc en patois
comme moi conjugale avec le coût de ce
moment que vous allez passer ensemble je
crois que c'est une très bonne
opportunité déjà d'un peu mieux se
connaître entre services qui sont
voisins allemands se connaissent assez
peu puis après je pense que c'est bien
c'est une manifestation qui met la
relation humaine
en avant et ça me paraît toujours très
bonne chose de faire ça et après une
fois que je rentrais dans les locaux
ci-après fois que j'avais la chance de
visiter un petit peu les studios la deux
côté télévision donc c'est une première
pour moi
[Musique]
nous
je
[Musique]
le
non
[Musique]
le
non
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il va 800 au vlt
je
[Musique]
magna la miaj
oui vous êtes où
[Musique]
m
nous sommes
le tueur
[Musique]
comme aussi toile est un métier
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non